what's a statesman what's the difference
between politician and a statesman go to
a statesman what's a statesman about
what's a politician about they're wired
in a different way it's not the same
wiring you know mansion is a statesman
you know some of the guys on the right
that disagree with trump they're
statesmen you have to like tucker going
up there and
disagreeing with what trump was doing
how many times have you seen tucker
interview trump why do you think i don't
know people realize this trump is not a
big fan of tucker how many times have
you seen trump interview with hannity i
never watch it yeah you know and if i
watch it i watch it because we're
talking about it on the podcast because
to to hannah these eyes trump can't do
no wrong so it's not it's not so i think
i i think true statesmen today
uh uh are tough to come by but if
somebody truly wants to make history
instead of getting the check mark
i think you got to study the greatest
statement in the history of america and
see what they went through what was
their formula how did they think why did
they do what they did it's a little bit
more about what you were talking about
earlier on dying on the sword and all
that stuff a true state statesman is
country over your
policies it's not policies country over
your politics country over you being
liked and you don't find a lot of people
like that who would you even put as the
top statesman in america today
today today who's up there you said joe
manchin okay he's on the list is is bill
maher on that list is joe rogan on the
list does it have to be a politician who
in politics is a true statement a
statesman who is a synergist who's not a
divider who do you actually put on that
list today i know that you're a big fan
of tulsi gabbard is she is a true
statesman states woman who who actually
is on that list just an amish tom massey
uh i'd give it to rand paul um
mansion
for sure
uh
who's the guy from south dakota those
are all people that
south dakota
wyoming you're talking about south
carolina south carolina lindsey graham
not lindsey graham no no no no tim uh
tim scott uh maybe i'm not even saying
the state right the guy that we had on
we uh jose interviewed him what's uh uh
oh you're like trey gowdy trey gowdy
yeah
i
so if you enjoyed this little short
segment from the podcast that we did
here's another short segment to watch or
if you want to see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody
bye-bye
[Music]
you